un premier voyage au Canada pour le
secrétaire d'État américain Anthony
brinken
mais de notre amitié face à ces défis et
comme disait ministre au travail
rencontre de membres de la diaspora
ukrainienne dans un café
et de photos à la maison d'accueil du
gouvernement canadien ont donné lieu à
des échanges amicaux
une discussion sur la même longueur
d'onde avec Justin Trudeau renforçant
l'idée que les relations entre les
États-Unis et le Canada coule de source
qui manquent sur la table de travail la
guerre en Ukraine le droit des femmes en
Iran la souveraineté de l'article
l'entente sur les tiers pays sur
puis il y a la crise sécuritaire et
humanitaire en Haïti la manière
d'intervenir demeure une question
délicate la ligne semble mince entre une
main tendue et de l'ingérence
nous avons tous les deux eu des avec
différents pays pour sonder leur intérêt
et leur volonté d’intervenir en Haïti
indique une tenue brinken aucun décision
qui va être prise sans l'implication des
Haïtiens j'ai toujours dit ça sera par
et pour les Haïtiens parce qu'au final
c'est pour leur bien parce que
présentement c'est le peuple qui souffre
en Haïti alors notre objectif c'est de
les aider eux l'ancien ambassadeur du
Canada en Haïti crois que le
gouvernement estien doit d'abord se
concentrer sur la mise en place d'un
pouvoir légitime de route claire pour
les élections je suis sûr que le Canada
s'engagerait à appuyer un conseil
électoral provisoire une mission de
supervision des Nations Unies sur le
processus électoral en fait le genre de
choses qu'on a fait depuis 20 ans mais
ça prend ça sociologue croient que le
Canada doit intervenir mais avec
prudence pour éviter de répéter les
erreurs du passé le gouvernement du
Canada qui prend le leadership de ça
droit trouver la voie de passage une
voix de passage qui est légale une voie
de passage qui respecte la const
haïtienne qui respectent les règles
internationales les voisins et alliés
s'entendent sur bien des points mais
leur vision des troubles en Haïti
divergent pour les États-Unis c'est
d'abord une question de sécurité alors
que pour le Canada il s'agit plutôt
d'une crise humanitaire ici Valérie
Michaela
Ottawa